Welcome back to the next module of the advanced operating systems course. Recall
that the Cornell experiment that we saw as the last
piece of the previous module argues for a component based
design to reduce the pain points in the development of complex software
systems. And industries that are designing and commercializing
production operating systems and distributed services
through the client-server paradigm, there is
another important pain point. And that is how to design for the
continuous and incremental evolution of complex
distributed software systems, both in terms
of functionality and performance. The short answer to the puzzle is distributed
object technology. We saw how object
technology is employed in the Tornado parallel
operating system as a structuring tool
to allow the scalability of operating system
services in a parallel system. In this module of the advanced operating systems
course, we are going to see examples of how distributed object technology is
influencing commercial offerings in the computer industry.
We'll start this lesson module with the
discussion of the Spring system, which was
designed and implemented in Sun Micro Systems
as a network operating system for use in a local area network. Later on,
Spring was marketed as Sun's Solaris operating
system. Before we discuss the Spring system,
a little bit of history and some personal connection. Yousef Khalidi, one of the
chief architects of the spring system, got his PhD from Georgia Tech in
1989 developing the cloud's distributing operating system,
which is an object based operating system.
And he was my numero uno PhD
student incidentally. Not surprisingly, the Spring system
was heavily influenced by Yousef's work with
clouds. And Spring came out commercially as
Sun's Solaris MC product. And for the trivia buffs out there, Yousef is now
heading Microsoft's Azure Cloud Computing product. By
the way, Azure has nothing to do
with the cloud system that Yousef developed
as a grad student at Georgia Tech. Later
on, when we discuss giant scale services and cloud computing, we will feature an
interview with Yousef wherein he shares his
thoughts on future evolution of distributed system services.